what is the theoretically fastest way
that you could get from LA to San
Francisco for reason TV I'm Justin
Monticello I'm here today with Dirk
Albourne who's the CEO and co-founder of
jumpstart fund and also the CEO of
Hyperloop transportation technologies
Dirk thank you for speaking with us
today
thank you for having me Elon Musk of
SpaceX and Tesla and PayPal introduced
this idea of a Hyperloop in 2012 it's
this cost me to Concord a railgun and an
air-hockey table can you just give us an
explanation of what the Hyperloop is so
imagine a capsule was 28 people that's
hovering inside the tube at really high
speeds of 7 at 60 miles per hour it's
completely solar-powered it's cheaper to
be built
it's Earthquake stable can never crash
it is immune to weather that I believe
would go effectively faster than the
speed of sound you could conceivably
live in temperatures go to work in LA
what's the difference between a
Hyperloop and let's say a maglev train
like those in Japan that ride on magnets
the propulsion and levitation is you
know there's different ways in which you
can do it the original Hyperloop
proposal was talking about a skis meter
and a half long paddles that use the air
around them to create pressurized
cushions of air on which the pod can
ride like a air hockey table or may will
be smooth as glass the real difference
is actually in the tube so with the
Hyperloop you have a low-pressure
environment so it's very similar to when
an airplane is really high
it doesn't encounter a lot of resistance
and then you have in front of the
capsule the compressor that takes away
the air so the remaining resistance
moves us to the back so that basically
the capsule it doesn't touch anywhere it
doesn't have resistance in the front and
it can just hover with little energy and
reach those top speeds at 7 and 60 miles
per hour and in terms of within cities
themselves do you think it could
revolutionize shorter transportation as
well if you get from LA to San Francisco
and 34 34 35 minutes which is more or
less what we have planned right now was
a hype
that's awesome but if it takes you an
hour and a half to get to the station
we haven't really solved the problem so
what we really what we are really
working on is to create a way where you
just take out your phone you push a
button and let's say within 15 minutes
you are in San Francisco so a
self-driving car comes picks you up
brings you to the local Hyperloop
station so a mini loop inside the city
that then takes you to the larger
station which takes you up to San
Francisco so it has to be an integrated
system it has to be something that you
use every day several times that's
really when we change the way people
live so he initially proposed this as a
response to California's plans to build
a high-speed rail it has a dubious
distinction of being the slowest bullet
train and the most expensive per mile
so can you kind of give us an idea of
the major differences between this
project versus a rail system they're way
slower than we would be and way more
expensive so most high-speed rail
projects actually do not make money our
whole concept is based on the fact that
this is a business it's a venture we
don't rely on public funding necessarily
in dollar amounts what would you be
looking at for a Hyperloop from LA to
San Francisco versus you know a rail
system 10 to 20 percent so we're looking
at 16 billion dollars but again I
actually personally believe it will be
much less than with the ticket price of
approximately $30 how does the
environmental impact compare Hyperloop
has no environmental impact if you want
so it's completely self-powered we very
likely actually will produce energy the
Hyperloop is on pylons so we are taking
way less land where you can you would
use publicly available right-of-way like
like the i-5 we don't have to go through
fields like a highway or rail let's talk
a little bit of the beginning about
jumpstart funds so this is a a company
or a platform that you started in 2013
that is supposed to enable better crowd
sourcing so can you explain to us how
how it works and how yes sure so we're
trying to mix open
source methods with a commercial company
here having 500,000 people that are
helping you to make your engineer
project a success you can build a better
company so in in the case it was a
Hyperloop what we did is we saw that
there was a huge interest from people to
actually make this happen be part of it
so we opened up the company we're
collaborating with Supra Studios at UCLA
and a lot of really amazing people so
from a Stanford psychology professor to
a guy that helped build a mouse-over
then working with the community so with
the general public and the community on
the sides to get more insights we have
10% of the future revenues that are
reserved to the community and how is
this approach to creating this project
different from the way that the
California government has approached the
high speed rail project
you know normally these projects are you
know decided somewhere in a boardroom
build and then something's wrong or
something doesn't really work the way it
is or you don't have so many people as
you saw that actually going to use it so
this is the first time that a project of
the size has ever been done like this so
we are trying to work with the public
completely in an open way we want to
show how the interior of the capsule is
going to look like how is it going to
feel we're asking people to come up with
ideas on how we can reduce the ticket
price come up with our business model
I'm actually just I'm just here because
someone has to be the CEO but we are a
crowd powered company so actually when
when we started I met Tim Draper the
venture capitalists he told me and
that's amazing if you guys are
successful what do we have governments
for are you looking at the regulatory
side now or we actually we're actually
not trying to get to distract it too
much because if we can build it then
there is no reason to think about the
politics at what point in the process of
developing this are you right now
Elon Musk announced that he will be
building a test track in Texas it will
be a small scale version that's great
for us because we can test parts of our
systems out there but to
being able to build LA to San Francisco
we have to do a full-scale version that
people are using where we can you know
optimize everything today announcing a
deal struck with the developers in Quay
Valley California Carl where they will
build a 5-mile stretch of their version
of the Hyperloop you're starting
construction next year right on an
actually fully functional urban version
of the Hyperloop we are doing a public
offering that's scheduled for the end of
the year where we will raise the funds
needed in order to build the first
project we hope we can get this done by
2018 what do you think are the biggest
hurdles that you're going to face people
are afraid of new technologies they
don't understand it I think it's going
to do the same thing that's a rail
actually did to America when when it
first got introduced in the 1800 you
know and obviously the naysayers are
very similar so a lot of people at that
time were thinking that you would die
when you go on a train because it goes
so fast you couldn't breathe so once
you're starting to build and people can
actually try it out I don't I don't
think anything can stop it all right der
Colburn I thank you for speaking with me
thank you for having me